my guest this week for the new revamped
relaunched fan funded Reuben report is a
comedy legend an activist and author an
actress and entrepreneur and a former
presidential candidate roseanne plus
mother and grandmother don't forget the
most important part I should have done
those two first right but you know
that's how you are ah that's okay I've
made the correction all right let's jump
right into your sir there that's so rad
there's B you told me once I loved her
that you loved her but you also told me
that you thought that the gay community
rallied behind the Golden Girls in a
weird way that they didn't quite behind
you even though you were actually doing
a lot more Pro gay stuff because you did
the first gay kiss which we'll talk
about later and all that stuff is that a
weird thing because it was sort of like
the Conners were sort of the reverse of
what people think of as gay is
over-the-top and flamboyant and the
Conners were working-class that's not
thought of as yeah so do some some some
working-class people our games there are
they are sum up a market they're not on
Bravo though well they're gonna they're
right next to Bravo on TLC like the duck
dynasty I mean you know come on those
guys there's a lot of gays in that
family yeah I don't know they they
looked really gay at first I saw it on
the internet and they were like in these
golf shirts and [ __ ] and they were all
clean-shaven Republicans right which
kind of means gay right right right
and then they grew the beards to get the
show and and I think they did have the
southern accents but I watch that show
the other day I think it's cry I'm
transfixed by these reality shows are
very good you had your own reality show
I had two or three of them what was the
ad Roseanne's nuts which I loved
yeah there were more bleeps you had more
bleeps per minute than anything I've
ever seen he would say that I was
difficult but you know that's how I
talked they want to see the real me I
mean if they didn't want to see the real
me I could never figure out well why
don't you go higher
uh you know Raquel Welch or somebody
write that right you don't want to see
me
I saw one episode you were on like a
truck and you were like plowing through
the macadamia things and you were
clearing brush in the box
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah getting my aggression out
yeah
and killing a you know non-indigenous um
what do you call it
colonial growth off my pure Pele nest so
you had so the macadamia stuff that is
indigenous to no it's not it's from New
Zealand really the maxi the Big Island
Hawaii where I live that was the world's
lab laboratory where all those people
went and they did experiments in the
earth of what would grow you know and so
those macadamia nuts are not indigenous
really they they are from New Zealand
and they were brought over at the very
same time when the pineapple which is
not indigenous to the Big Island of
Hawaii was brought there too so they
were manufacturing this perfect cyborg
biosphere right and and they have been
since the late 1800s on the Big Island
you're blowing my mind or your sunny
macadam is a [ __ ] farm or what but
macadamia nuts and pineapples are
neither indigenous to Hawaii no not the
kind they brought over huh they brought
the pineapple from other Hawaiian
Islands and then they brought the papaya
and the mango and they totally GMO
manufactured the papaya that's why you
know that's why end up running for
president because I was part of kickin
yeah Monsanto's ass off the Big Island
Hawaii and we did win and we did kick
Monsanto out and I are so proud of that
because I alt I might be like you know
I'm meditating stuff so I'd be like what
would be the best words I always
meditate for the right words because I'm
a comic that's what we do we're always
looking forward
mm-hmm that fit and whatever I very
seldom brag about myself my writing and
stuff or maybe I do it too much
somehow my dreams I pass what you do
have 18 cups here I'm not sure what's
going on here
water coffee and my specialty
the specialty yeah for my voice yeah
we'll keep that one quiet
remember Jackie Gleason that was my
favorite thing I know it has a little
girl yeah he take that drinker and Jack
Paar to they act like they're drinking
you knew it was you just looked for how
where the you knew it was because I did
that bit so many times people used to be
able to drink on television right now
people here would be smoking I mean
Johnny Carson smoking cigarettes and
they were drinking and having a good
time and now everything's where they
couldn't swear we can say whatever you
want you want to throw an f-bomb right
now just for just an extra one no
because that kicks in my OCD oh so if we
lo if we throw one and it could unfurl
though it will it will it's like don't
even go there just like that first drink
you know I I go to Alcoholics ah I think
you just blew you out of this whenever
that have spent oh gosh you're right
that that you should write that down get
that down [ __ ] pan I never have
[ __ ] pan while you're thinking so I
already forgot my [ __ ] idea isn't
that the word what do you want to say I
feel like I'm in therapy because I
thought BR about being the gays and
great yeah so but be in the gays I mean
gay I don't know I don't know either
I saw her sing this song to her husband
on Broadway because I went and she saw
her play oh I saw the play yeah what's
not up great it was wonderful it was
wonderful it's all like old Oh her old
stories and what it was like to be
trapped in that little TV box which you
know you would you know all about I just
like her boy so much everybody thinks
that that's what'll be miss of that boys
yeah it was such a genius once in a
lifetime boys and when she sang it was
so beautiful yeah but it was her boys
singing and boy she was a master of that
oh yeah few people are what do you think
about that that my idea of that the the
gays rallied around the Golden Girls in
a way that they maybe didn't around
Roseanne but you did I mean that kiss I
remember watching that kiss whatever
year that was maybe 97 or something and
it was Natalie
and bars all over America yeah we were
trying there wasn't technology then but
we were trying to hook up phone calls to
like it essential but now of course it
all be you know I don't know what they
do now
yeah bouncing off Mars I just something
with my I know it's involved with Martha
very technological now yeah so I wish I
was working then when it was high-tech
like that well you're working right now
well in my own studio uh you know I just
got on this kit cuz I have really bad
OCD but I just wanted to know what does
it feel like to own your own work and
just like say what you want to say and
be who you really are it it takes a lot
of sacrifice man yeah I mean we have
been working without the ass every day
we have been I've never worked harder in
my life than we've worked in these last
couple months as we've put this thing
together well you got to work hard yeah
you got to pay the [ __ ] cost to be
the [ __ ] boss I ain't no [ __ ]
yeah you only say come no you didn't own
it
I own a percentage of it right that
makes me you know I could go like I do
get depressed over that they owned 20%
of my own work mm-hmm
and I put I'm the one that put my life
on the line that would certainly one any
committee involved there but every joke
there was a [ __ ] committee involved
but at the final hour I just say what I
want in front of the camera and let the
audience decide if I got a bigger laugh
than all them writers then we kept that
yeah and if they got a bigger left of me
we kept that I mean I cared about the
product yeah and aside from all the
other names they call me [ __ ] [ __ ] and
all that [ __ ] cuz you know whatever um
you know it's important that an artist
control his or her own wife and product
and everything I mean that an action
ain't free for somebody to setae isn't
it cool that we're cutting out the
network's now in a way because look I
mean we I think so yeah like I own this
thing I have no I don't have to answer
it in you know you're gonna work [ __ ]
hard Joe you're not no [ __ ] Democrats
are we gonna get to the [ __ ]
elections or what
we're all over the place here you would
I know that's me yeah I'm with you
uh-huh I'm cool
so you want to go to the elections no go
where you want you're running this [ __ ]
I am I guess I want some of this man G
all right let's go to the elections
let's go to the elections is that really
where you want to go the elections
Roseanne we are in the craziest time
that I ever remember in America right
now just [ __ ] PT Barnum on [ __ ]
drugs that's what it feels like yeah
it's awesome yeah you loved it I loved
every [ __ ] second of it yeah I can
never sleep I'm up like I can't stop
reading it's so fascinating seeing what
they're doing to us all that you know
they're really trying to factionalized
us they're trying to divide us they're
trying to how to divide us on every
single non-issue they can dream up you
don't like Hillary I know that much
right you're not a Hillary I'm not a
honey Hillary not Hillary I like her
I've met and had dinner and lunch with
her I've spoken to her about women's
issues and Jewish issues and things like
that and charities and how I I don't
think that charities should you know I
do think charity should be above being
taxed mm-hmm but by god they shouldn't
have a [ __ ] banks worth of money if
they're trying to help people right they
shouldn't be buying [ __ ] property and
Dubai rights easily say about a
profit-making charity that right there I
start I start seeing the duality of
everything I mean before that yeah I saw
something just a double [ __ ] am i double
mind [ __ ] a double double talking Big
Brother mind [ __ ] or the rich is getting
way richer anybody who's contaminated
with money is a felt they dirty [ __ ]
rat and that's the bottom line
capitalism is in it's on its deathbed so
what do you think is the better option
because I want to talk about the movie a
little bit and you talk about sort of
socialism but not not sort of fashion
war so socially so not just stoplights
streets and I believe healthcare you pay
your taxes to get something you pay your
taxes and as I say search exoteric lis
in my movie
a decent socialist structure one
receives healthcare or something for
their taxes schools then they don't turn
around pay their checks and then pay for
schools - mm-hmm
this is national socialism and that's I
don't like that one that's not a good
system because it's based on a vampire
capitalism and that's what's dying right
it should die and people should take a
deep [ __ ] breath tighten that belt
take a step back and let it go stop
trying to prop it up it's supposed to
die cuz it doesn't work yeah it's evil
so you're not talking about capitalism
just capitalism that's up you're talking
about this crony capitalism and the way
they've rigged everything the modern
kings Bob see they said they say and do
the opposite of what they when they say
free markets they don't mean free
markets they mean free markets for
slavers now that's a fixed and rigged
[ __ ] system against most people so
that's what that's what's going on here
right it's sort of like the internet
made people wake up to some level of
reality that the media is kind of in it
with I think some people I think I mean
I see what people are saying to me like
people are waking up to just how rigged
the system is how everyone is being
pitted the media pits everybody against
everybody I mean turn on the TV right
now what's going on with black lives
matter because that's what I wanted
that's why I ran for president oh I I
made the movie and I think my movie
roseann for president which is out now
yeah it it shows where I planted the
season I knew right where to plant them
so and I feel just so vindicated I feel
really powerful like as I did I did find
bright words and I always will try to
find right words the good thing about
right words is they turn off idiots and
we don't need any of them
the less of them interpreting and
mansplaining and [ __ ] go explaining
and your Empire's feral splaining are
[ __ ] when it is about profit sharing
it's that [ __ ] simple you have to pay
people decently for working and every
problem on earth disappears them with
the minute
that happens because they only have wars
for slavery that's why they have were so
they can have slay bêlit slave labor so
they have a [ __ ] war well the less we
would war the more money for us that's
that's what I'm saying mmm it's not dude
that just this one time let's instead
step back let it fall learn how to grow
our own food this is number one mmm food
is money and getting our water
harvesting our you know surviving we've
got a step back from the [ __ ] it
doesn't matter which one of them wins
it's the same [ __ ] it's a doo-wop
allistic fundraising arm of the prison
military-industrial complex and you know
brags it to me was [ __ ] the heroes
that was the heroes try the rebel yell I
love it yeah cuz we don't I thought we
didn't want this one world government
and we're back in the 90s remember they
were yes with the one world [ __ ] evil
and you loominatee they were working up
some fat [ __ ] right which I went
right in the heart of that too and I'm
like I know what you're doing and when
you tell people you know what they're
doing
it explodes them so what do you make of
the whole black lives matter thing
because this is this is it I mean I feel
like this is going to be the issue until
the election and probably much much
longer than that well I have black
teenage males in my family it's very
frightening and it you know it's you
know that's not like they're making it
up it's true and real you know it
happens too often it happens to
Hispanics a lot here too but they don't
report it as much mm-hmm and they're
also locked up hand over fist um but
it's just you know it's the news again
wagging the dog yeah so the news
basically wants us all to hate each
other right like it's just about good
stories that interest us that's all it's
it's speaking to the demographic that it
wants to fleece yeah hello capitalism
yeah
so what am i bal [ __ ] how do we get some
smart people - you don't i'm it's me
that's it that's all there [ __ ] is
that's it and i'm so tired of people not
seeing that but you know i i've gone
crazy over it for quite a while been
like well you know and you know as a jew
i believe that everything does happen
for the good is that a jew thought that
they didn't end up well because the
history of the jews a lot of bad stuff
happened it's been an sort of a one
endless bad thing after another all
along you know to be like we've been
pogroms and holocaust it and some other
stuff yes so we're so how does it get to
the good part just this once we will do
the right thing just this one time
please
I saw a my prayer is just this one time
we would don't listen he's [ __ ] paid
left us fake left [ __ ] they're full
of [ __ ] [ __ ] they're anti-union so
you calm it I say we can put the PAL
back in Palestine Palestinian yeah cuz
you know to me as an old socialist and
so were my grandfather's grandmother's
they were the [ __ ] [ __ ] that thought
this [ __ ] up they weren't greedy pigs
and they didn't want to kill people
mm-hmm they just want a profit-sharing
want to be paid fairly for their labor
and I think that that's the only real
issue on earth and everything is a labor
issue that can easily be solved if you
take all the drama and [ __ ] out of
it and it could be easily [ __ ] fixed
and then we would so evolved to such a
[ __ ] different place and I think
we're going there our technology proves
that we're going there and at the top of
the pyramids where those programmers sit
there's a lot of really moral people
more and more because I think that you
at some point I say after that dark
night of the soul that we all have
rich poor will any color whatever every
culture you got to make the decision to
look yourself in the face in the mirror
and some people they don't have no
reflection hmm and no self reflection
means they're not they're not really a
person they're not really human so
basically being present I think what
you're saying sort of being present in
your own way often in a way being aware
is really so hard it's hard but it's
really the most human thing you can do
right because that's how you don't get
manipulated by all these people that are
trying to split us all the time only you
can do this then then you can avoid that
yeah evil isn't really a person although
there are people who follow evil mm-hmm
but evil itself is it's a thought so
it's easy to turn it off yeah and it
should be turned off yeah that's why I
always talk about ideas on this show
because I believe that good ideas will
always be bad ideas if you let them be
spoke of we're now yeah what kind of
crazy [ __ ] yeah that was crazy yeah
after what I've listened to for 20
minutes that's the gap schedule is crazy
explain that good ideas that if that we
have to have free speech and let
everyone say whatever they got that can
be read read I'm real freedom that real
freedom will feel good yeah cuz freedom
only works for good it never works for
bad and I mean there's a very good oh
yeah
freedom always works for unity profit
sharing justice for women and children
right nobody ever said I'm too free
right no Society was ever well why did
they crumble well they were too free I
never had well they'll say that [ __ ]
right I understand what they're saying
because you can't let it be free for
slavers you can't let it be free for
evildoers they they take away everybody
else freedom you got to be for freedom
and sometimes what you're going to do to
defend against those who don't want you
to have freedom therein lies in the fish
there's the [ __ ] right right that's
where the rubber meets the road right
mm-hmm so you were always into all this
right you were always
because thinking about it I mean the
show Roseanne you know buddy did what
you did you took a family that was
struggling at almost every episode had
some struggle delivery where I mean
honestly he him and Jackie Gleason and
um even Red Skelton and Lucy I mean
everybody uh you didn't know Lucy was
rich or nothing when she's just in that
one room right but you did it I guess at
a time when maybe sitcoms understand
there was a road paved for me I didn't
just come out of nowhere there was a
road paved for me right I guess maybe
what I meant is that you did it at a
time when I think we're all dark was
that mild Molly Goldberg that's a law
it's a remake now but I said even a
remake this is the Goldbergs now have
something to do with that goldberg show
that's right
but I guess what I meant is that your
show came on when when Cosby showed a
very middle up you know sort of middle
class or he almost upper middle-class
black family which was really
interesting and groundbreaking and then
you came in and said here's what middle
America the part that everyone forgets
la doesn't care about them New York
mocks them whatever it is you came in
and said this is what I'm gonna do and
the jokes were real everything about it
the fights that you and and Dan had they
were that you and John Goodman had I
mean everything it was real so you
always did you always realize that that
was what that what you wanted to do yeah
that was my goal like [ __ ] them
[ __ ] I'll show them yeah and I
knew why they were doing it too and it
was a a real woman shaming thing and I
didn't like that well what was one of
Jamie television and it pissed me off
sighs like a [ __ ] you know I'm gonna get
in there and do this and it just started
forming you know how an idea comes and
then you know the jokes came it's always
about the jokes of course yeah I was
always just looking for a place to put
my jurors I just love jokes yeah I loved
they just come to me how I speak in
jokes on so I'm a comic you know yeah
but uh know there's a lot of thought in
comedy and
or smart we need more good comedy now
don't you think like we fit I feel like
we don't like I every morning I wake up
and I see something the news and I'm
like [ __ ] if only George Carlin was
around for this you know I gotta give it
up to a Doug Stanhope I do think he's
this this day and age one a George
Carlin types or children or whatever you
call it you know HOF Springs or whatever
yeah but I have to say that I went down
to met seashores The Comedy Store there
Mitzi gave us all our starts yeah Thank
You Mitzi and Tuesday night is uh my
camp member the name because I remember
anything that's all black comics mm-hmm
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] on it hair I've seen
anything like it yeah they're
mixed-media they're doing with
mixed-media it's genius
I could and they let me come come up and
dance but oh there's some genius comics
on Tuesday night a main room comedy
store movie star level brilliant
physical as well you know the we used to
have those different comics we'd have
like a physical guy a guy did characters
a guy who sang it did impressions mm-hmm
these are all that with one yeah it's
scary genius Wow and I love seeing scary
genius comedy and I've seen a lot of it
you know it's out there it's coming you
know if Trump wins is a good only good
part really is this can be so great for
comedy I mean oh my god the jokes will
just [ __ ] right the jokes will be
great for us but not great for the
country bro no I think it laughing is
good for the country but yeah if Hillary
gets in it'll be like I'm offended yeah
so if Hillary that's but that's my thing
right now we're on a I don't know any
[ __ ] jokes I don't know what I'm
doing I don't have no Obama jokes yeah
you tell me I mean nobody did it right
people whisper Obama jokes yeah
but few of them are funny they're just
stereotypes but some are funny yeah so
Milo who we've talked about he's got
some funny well he told me that night I
get this part of why he's supporting
Trump he told me that that this election
has nothing
to do with politics it's purely on
culture it's on this swing man it's
basically that's what he said he'll yeah
he's trying they got hit they got into
him in the CIA and the FBI and you know
the Federal Reserve they got to do
everything they can to make Hillary look
good to us they're going do something
they're going to some extremes
so you think Trump's a mother never very
good you think oh yeah not too many fun
not goods around her she should shred
him but she doesn't she doesn't shed any
bad so that's scary right it just sticks
with her yeah Pfizer and I'd be like
[ __ ] I did say no I'm not gonna take a
dime from you [ __ ]
got my own my own need your [ __ ] so you
kind of did this it was like what I paid
for it when I was out Trump you know
when he was running in the primaries I
could sail he see he was stealing my
[ __ ] right and left so was Bernie
Hillary started stealing my [ __ ] on my
show this one reporter from France came
over and she interviewed me for some big
intellectual [ __ ] that only Jesuits
read you know and she said would there
be Hillary Clinton without Roseanne
Connor I said absolutely not there won't
be a Sarah Palin either without Roseanne
Connor
I'm not saying Roseanne Barr except for
you know I did and make that character
but that carriers got a life of its own
it's my Frankenstein so how do we keep
pushing out good stuff how do you get
good that's what I'm trying to do is get
some good stuff through the noise and
it's tough but people want it because I
see it every day people are gone
wow-whee needs people want to be smart
and yet the system is designed to make
them dumb mm-hmm so how do you fight
through that well you have to meditate
and you have to find the silence inside
that can combat [ __ ] you know like
like super lady superwoman yeah
bracelets uh you have to find the calm
place in your mentality to just sit and
behold be aware be aware and behold and
do
thing just be aware and you can do it by
you know three steps breathing in
holding the breath and exhaling them
breath you know that used to be called
count to ten but it is kind of counting
to ten but afterward when you do it you
have some peace in your mind when you
don't contain any programming or
[ __ ] you're just open and you feel
rather than think and you feel breath in
your body right after that you can see a
lot clearer that's a good thing to think
about rather than Hillary and Trump be
in your body and be aware of your body
of the food you grow and the excess of
the food for profit-sharing because you
might have to share your profit with
your neighbors in order for them to bard
or something of equal value to you
because you're gonna probably be without
money so these are real things not
[ __ ] things money's paper is
[ __ ]
doesn't exist anymore not backed up by
anything just paper well why do you work
so hard to get paper for food shelter
clothing and community and safety well
you already got that [ __ ] if you work it
it's right in front of you like cows are
in a pasture full of food we got that's
how the world really is when you don't
have money
Oh [ __ ] there anyway you don't need
paper grow a tomato right don't need to
work people should be working four to
six hours a week we talked about weed
yeah let's talk about some we'd talk
about it by having if ya if ya there was
some weed around here before and I know
you smoked the good stuff because I've
smoked some of your weed before yeah you
got that oil I know I did the oil and it
was almost like being on something else
that isn't weed that isn't weed i man
I do thinking something beside weed oh
there's something else at the Royal Bay
Oriole is something else yeah so you in
the movie you talk about how you think
that weed could actually I mean
everything that you're talking about
here from the you know out there stuff
to whatever it is it's sort of related
back to just kind of freeing the mind
your whole thing is thank freeing the
mind thinking about things yeah so why
is it like that I like starting from
there why why is it like this not how
did it get that way cuz there's a lot of
[ __ ] idiots say how did it get that
way right I was inducted into a real
smart group when I was very young and my
teacher told me only victims asked why
or how did it get like that not so there
that's their sphere out right that's the
reality remember or something else right
that's something because we live in such
a victim culture right everyone is
always well I always talk about the
oppression Olympics here where
everyone's trying to show you how
they're the most oppressed and the
system's most rig begins them but what
you're saying is don't it's not about
why it is but now it's about just it is
it is it is so now use it right like
that's the next step as you're saying
it's his fault I can't change it Wow
[ __ ] my pants oh that's big baby [ __ ]
there's a grandmother [ __ ]
that's big one baby [ __ ] and women
change their pants forever but I mean
come on
Scott we got to take care of each other
we can't we can't huh we got to put our
heads together and figure how change the
system so that it works for people
that's hardcore range so whether it's
Trump or whether it's Hillary don't
matter
that's not trumpet that's not oh boy I
see all these people are going to get
mobilized they're going to be like we've
got to take control of our local
government in fact that is what you have
to do and that was what was so great
about kicking Monsanto off the big
island because Monsanto wasn't just
trying to legislate the type of seeds I
could use they were doing that yeah on
your own land that's what they're trying
to tell you what to do then that's what
they do here yeah I'm just trying to
watch what grows on my own
right because that was like all the
experiments for a hundred years by dull
pineapple and [ __ ] some odd [ __ ] [ __ ]
grows over there right I like take
pictures of it it's crazy
mm-hmm oh I know what I was going to say
not only were they try to tell us what
we could plant but what the real thing
is is they were trying to make local
government obsolete and that is what
they really do and they all do two
things the one is the circus for idiots
I shouldn't even say idiots the unaware
yeah and then there's a real [ __ ] and
they're trying to make local government
illegal for Christ's sake
that's what the Patriot Act is really
about so how do you fight the fight
you've got to get involved at the local
the smallest level is what matters
because that's how they did it that's
how they brought fascism to our country
using the war on drugs which was really
a war for drugs and I say it's rich
people on prescription drugs locking up
poor people on street drugs that's a war
on drugs for drugs and they brought
Mexico Edmond and Bill Clinton did it
all and there they are yeah we want him
back he sent all our jobs away
NAFTA got rid of aid to dependent
children some [ __ ] instead of
universal health care yes I mean if she
gets in I imagine the equal amount of
people on the other side are going to
get mobilized and start running for
office too and this is the great thing
if there is anything great about
democracy it's that you got to work it
for it to work however I did have lunch
one time with a royal I won't say who
because you know I don't want to put
them it was there a good person okay and
she he told me said this was their
feeling on the subject people did a lot
better under Kings because you know the
King would take care of his laborers he
had to I mean you know I have some
slaves - she didn't see that
like it somehow they forgot that house
is for him mm-hmm you know we let them
have doctors that go to college and what
they [ __ ] do they start talking about
democracy and that's what they get and
visit Victor Hugo said democracy is two
walls and a lamb deciding what to have
for lunch so it's the wild wild East and
West but there is a political
compromising between the two and that's
what I write about I do believe in
freedom so it seems to me that a lot of
the things that you're talking about
we're sort of all over the place here
but there is a there's a theme here sort
of around socialism but at the same time
you're really talking about the
individual because you're basically
saying get your [ __ ] right think right
get local instead of yeah socialism as
the Socialists define socialism I'm for
some socialist solutions to problems
yeah but that doesn't mean that I'm a
Stalinist
it actually sounds libertarian to me a
lot of things don't like them because we
do need government yeah by God we need
intelligent efficient government so I I
you know I I want a synthesis called
people ISM where we just like solve
[ __ ] problem right and and nobody's
getting rich off keeping the problem
going so when you ran you ran first for
the Green Party for people that don't
know it so you ran the Green Party
ticket for the Green Party nomination
for the nomination and you eventually
lost to Jill Stein who has run how many
times eighty-seven times before
there's nothing Hey well their last
candidate before Jill Stein was Cynthia
McKinney right so was that if our heart
was Ralph Nader right right so Jill
though struck me as when I watch the
documentary she's very much like a
politician like a normal politician and
you came into the Green Party language
yeah she spoke just the writ but it
doesn't get you anywhere in the system
right it doesn't the Democrats and
Republicans if you just speak their
language but you're not one of them
that's not going to get you into the
system and you basically were like [ __ ]
this I'm gonna speak the way I speak I'm
gonna talk about these things and to me
they could have jumped on you and said
this would be at least a way of cracking
the system a little bit but they didn't
ultimately they didn't go with you
and they can stay tight and white and
you know they want the matching funds
again money I don't know on the local
level I'll say when I ran I did get the
nomination of the Peace and Freedom
Party and I was very excited because
they were a real Socialist Party but
then when I asked people to do work for
free they got along great
I got to make money for them and I said
you you don't get paid for being a
revolutionary and in my campaign you do
it because you have to do it you don't
do it firm job because those people I
sell you out
I want to true believers fire in the
bellies I got a few of them and made it
to three ballots because of them mm-hmm
and the work they did they go out there
got the signatures you got like the
sixth most amount of votes right yeah
only in only three states and I took
three states and put me in six place out
of 50 candidates so I thought oh these
are these are some good things that
people who come after can can you know
probably Kanye West will be doing it
until it was Roseanne Kanye I could see
it do you think we have a chance you
think we have a chance to get out of
this freaking thing so I get what you're
saying there's goodness coming people
are waking up and then yet you're also
talking about a lot of bad stuff but in
just terms of the political stuff you
think there'll be a chance like could
somebody actually good do it well I did
it yeah but but can someone break
through can I break this well that's the
question can somebody we can break
through in our own ways can you do me
yeah you're gonna do it I'm right here
you're gonna run in 2020 there anybody
else but me no there isn't and that's
what really [ __ ] pissed me off
because people are like oh she's doing
and everything and I wanted to show hey
what if you really run for the values
all of America says they believe in they
gotta vote for you no but I you know
that's disturbing because that's just
nothing but dirty mind control and when
you sit in front of people yourself
included sorry and you say no I I have
the answers I put a lot of thought into
how we're going to live through the
collapse of
ilysm show me one other candidate who's
saying anything like that and there
isn't any and then they go well is there
a chance somebody could say something
and I'm saying I'm saying it you know
but because I'm uh I think it's because
I'm a woman I do and hot and I'm just
too [ __ ] smart oh you know people
can't accept me I can't be responsible
if people don't want to hear it I had to
really separate out from that if you
don't want to hear it [ __ ] them no I
don't think that there's any hope that
we're gonna live through this [ __ ]
no I don't I think there's an infant is
Mille I think it's 99% that will be all
be dead within 40 years and the earth
with it hmm I think there's a 1% chance
that if we were to start taking care of
each other and valuing real [ __ ] like
each other's lives and getting food to
hungry kids and stopping all this
[ __ ] if on the off hand chance we
would ever do the right thing just this
once I have great hope that it would
save everything I I'm just so proud that
I I think that I wrote the words that
kicked Monsanto out of Hawaii and I know
that to myself that I I did that from my
grandkids and other people's grandkids
and so you just want to do what's right
for kids and I'm not gonna stop yeah I I
mean I think if I know anything about
you it's that you won't stop that seems
so obvious to me just knowing you're
your history which we barely touched on
and then everything with the show and
then everything I know about you now
like you this is the stuff like it's not
like one of these people that come on
shows or they talk one thing and they're
living something else I've never seen
you sorta have done that I did that I
did that the worst part of my life or I
like totally when all right let's do
this
whoo yes man I don't ever want to go in
there yeah was that like at your the
peak of your fame would
was that that was that time yeah awesome
isolated well yeah I was really I didn't
give me like a minute of that what's
that like when you when you at that
point you were making God knows how much
money and million are we yeah I mean
right so a million a week that be longer
there can that'd be that one didn't be
Beyonce lunch money now right but it was
pretty good for back then it was never
the highest it was pretty bright you you
knock Cosby off number one you ran that
you basically took full control of the
show pretty much although you were
fighting with executive still yeah and
all that stuff but what was that when
you think back to that period of your
life when you had that much power George
you know we don't have to talk about the
national anthem thing but the President
of the United States said that you're
you were despicable and now it's
afternoon that right okay so but but
that that are no right right now is the
doubts that wasn't here right here was
so what was that what was it like when
you think when you think about it like
what was it like to be that much of a
sort of cultural force it was really
lonely was scary lonely yeah psychopath
[ __ ] vampires everywhere yeah scary
lonely um real isolating lonely but it
got where you want to be if your comic
yeah I mean we're loners but we always
need somebody to you know be real with
and that's just how it goes
night I see it you know I lived through
it that's how I look at it and a lot of
other artists they didn't live through
it a lot of comics nowadays great comics
they're not living through it they're
homeless and I'm no teeth they were
great comics or snow nobody gets paid
for comedy nobody gets paid there's no
retirement or nothing
series they're like one moment that you
regret in this chaos of that that time
nothing right no cuz it's all like [ __ ]
I can sit all day and think if I want
and I do love it and read all day and
[ __ ] lay in bed and not take shower
for three days and have a stack of
magazines
somebody to bring me food land out could
you bring me yeah just great right and
you can fight with people on Twitter
that's pretty good yeah I got into that
Twitter thing yeah I tried to in gather
like-minded bulk and I I think that I've
introduced maybe 20 of them so that was
worth it
I think you got a couple people I like
introducing smart people to other smart
people and then they do something mm-hmm
and you know never call me again but
like take me up for dinner once a year
so don't ask me if I can Shepherd your
way through you two young people with
good ideas [ __ ] make something happen
leave me this you know make me proud of
you
I like introducing young people that
take action I'm proud of them but you
know I want to just lay lay in bed watch
my murder shows and go to Costco and get
the samples I know you like that - I
love it
ha ha ha it's so austere you do love it
every time I'm having a sample at Costco
I think Roseanne loves
Oh God and they're good that's pretty
good yeah real good they're good now
food chef that's great yeah they should
start selling the wine - I think but
they never do that they never do that
you can't get drunk and be riding one of
those giant carts oh those people are
all drunk yeah oh that I think yeah so I
want to ask over hangout I want because
one thing that you were sort of hitting
on you were that that I've talked about
for a long time now is what I call the
regressive left these people that are on
the left that don't actually stand for
liberal values you call it the fake left
yeah and I saw you charted on Twitter
probably two years ago before I was
really on this thing about their
aggressive you would always be talking
about the fake left when did you realize
that there was I ran for Greenport
president when I saw you know oh man
these guys are all rich they're just
wanting matching funds so they can go to
soirees and cocktail parties you know
instead oh I just met like somebody who
was a huge donor Democrat things this
was way back when
and their spouse was at a party the
spouse came in all in designer [ __ ] and
goes can I say something I'm having
labor I was like why do i why am I
always there to see it fun earth I'm
always there seeing my oh my [ __ ] god
why am I saying this yeah so of course I
can't shut up like you're gonna [ __ ]
you're you're gonna get your
[ __ ] ass sued and handed to you
there's labor laws look you can't break
[ __ ] labor laws can you not make your
maid wear a maid's outfit is that I
guess if they sign a holiday release or
some [ __ ] you tell them it's a reality
show around anything right but uh it's
all just [ __ ] [ __ ] they're not
pro-union when's the last time you heard
[ __ ] Jill Stein say a goddamn word
about union labor well it just doesn't
happen
yeah it's about boycotting Israel and
that's what they're all about because
that anti-semite [ __ ] it works and those
guys are those Pharaoh's right in the
chicks that's a great misdirection wait
so it's not the Jews writing the checks
though did you know it's Pharaoh's so
you've become a huge defender of Israel
which i think is amazing because I in
this business always been what I thought
was a defender of Israel on one eye um
that's why I was a little girl that was
my whole life this is you know Palestine
we called it before they stole that word
from us but my uncle's used to sing if
your name is a B join the Jewish Navy
five five five for Palestine that wasn't
you know that yeah that's how it was and
Palestine was where the Jews lived that
why they are boycott in Palestine yeah
yeah they have had a boycott on Jews
Arabs have four-way before Israel
existed hello it's just all [ __ ] and
I think that fake left what their cover
is they discover four empire an empire
you know royal Empire Pharaohs you know
they stole all the money of the Iraqi
Jews and kicked them out all the time
the fake left was not talking about
labor and and ethnic cleansing of Jewish
wealth in the Arab world because they
were getting paid by the Pharaohs to say
that [ __ ] I knew it was fake I knew it
was fake when I addressed the Green
Party delegates in Florida in 2011 and
I'm like you got to get rid of stand
your ground gun line they didn't know
about Trayvon Martin I think it hadn't
happened yet that was a
stand-your-ground I knew that was
[ __ ] not a good law for people hmm
you know and it's all based on how are
they going to get a lock-up pot-smoking
kids to go to those jails and work for
those corporations or 16 cents an hour
it's a predatory system I mean we know
enough to call it predatory lending but
it's way bigger and predatory lending
that's when you go to church to pray and
a pedo get you it's beyond predatory
it's a pirate predatory system and and
children are its prey and I don't like
them and I don't like anybody who aids
that and no gran must do grandpas don't
either okay but there peep there nodding
off at the television you don't have
kids or whatever decent people don't
like that kind of system and they don't
even dare look at it because they're
like this mm-hmm
you know that's like when Moses went and
you know he killed the past master you
know Moses was the Prince of Egypt
anyone who killed that TAS mayor cuz
it's like huh
you can't be
you're gonna somebody bigger than you is
gonna come along and I guess that's just
the history of the world right who's
ever got the [ __ ] hammer wins yeah and
the [ __ ] hammer violence and all that
war stuff um that comes with whoever can
write the checks for the armies always
money for more bombs right we don't have
money for roads but there's always money
for more bombs shut for now there's no
money so something new is here there's
no money sooner or later those chicks
are gonna bounce or some tragedy like
Dallas is gonna you know happen over and
over here and people are gonna have to
do something different
they're gonna have to take care of each
other that's like why it's kind of good
in a horrible way but I guess that's
what that's the good part that you talk
we're supposed to get to that anyway
that's what tells us we're supposed to
do just you know take care of each other
and yeah can we end this in a funny
manner yeah let's get through a funny
place to end this okay yeah I think it's
all funny at the end of it but this is
all proof while you're a comic right
like at the end of the day all this it's
all like at the end at the end I'll say
this at the end like my boyfriend Johnny
says he's quoting somebody and I can't
remember who but it's like everything
strung together with words everything's
a narrative and strung together with
words and history proves that yeah but
uh words can take it all apart too
that's why comedy is so [ __ ] great
cuz it's just like bam bam I'm shooting
right to the heart of the beast which is
in me I get I'm going to uh live for
truth like I say I do I'm gonna value
truth and talk it and live it mmm you
just you know value it no cuz
I know you want me down on something
funny I think idiots are funny well we
got plenty of those I laugh at the idiot
system and that's the thing as you say
about words laughing your idiot system
to scorn is the greatest gift that
comics freely offer a humanity and you
know like I said Doug Stanhope you
anybody who's funny or say anything real
[ __ ] go see em support them say go
further we want to hear more if I can
start laughing the [ __ ] to score
business just [ __ ] ridiculous it's
ridiculous that it doesn't work and that
it's like as stupid as it [ __ ] is all
right well listen I have a feeling oh
geez I have a feeling we're gonna do
this again but I just want to take a
second just to thank you because you we
met only in the last three years or so
but I feel like you somehow saw
something in me that uh not really no I
was just sure I was just really drunk no
I thought I could take a bong hit and
then said hi to me so are you and your
smile yeah you know you laughed at my
joke so I go this guy's a genius and
then we started talking and you were
really funny made me laugh anyone who
can make me laugh I just value them
especially now we all need to laugh all
right well holy cow thank you to
Roseanne Barr we did a lot there if you
can follow around there's something
there you can find out more about
Roseanne at Roseanne world.com and I'm
pretty sure if you smoke enough weed you
will find her on the celestial plane so
thanks for watching
I'll do it again next week
you